Film Courage: Pam, when you were taking The
Adderall Diaries as the memoir and then adapting
it into a screenplay, how much did you embellish
the drug use and sex scenes or did you try
to tone them down a bit?
Pamela Romanowsky: The drug use and the sex
scenes are actually toned down quite a bit.
I think that this was something that Stephen
(Elliott-The writer of the memoir) was very
interested in for the book and I was less
interested in for the film because for me
this film was about the relationships between
these characters and how consequences in those
relationships led to a realization in the
main character, so his unusual sex life and
his pretty moderate drug use are both parts
of that and part of who he is.
But to me, those are sort of just elements
of a character.
And I think that S&M is all over the media,
all over cinema right now and so to me it
wasn’t as shocking as it was in maybe 2008
when he was writing the book (and in 2009
when the book came out).
So it seemed pretty easy to me to accept that
it’s a part of this guy’s life and the
Adderall use is a part of his life and we
didn’t really need to talk about it that
much, it’s just part of who he is.
Film Courage: James, I think you’ve said
previously that Stephen writing the book was
not just a memoir, he was trying to create
a piece of art?
James Franco: (Recalling) O.k.
I think I know what you’re getting at.
Film Courage: How much do you feel about this
in your own work?
Because there are a lot of similarities between
the two of you.
You’re both very passionate, you go against
the grain, you’re both writers.
James: I think I was trying to define what
the book was more, meaning it’s not just
a straight memoir.
This book is not just “Then I did this….then
I did this…then I did this…”
There’s a more complicated kind of structure
or approach here where the way that he’s
remembering things, it is focused on and he
starts to question or highlight that process
in his self and extend it to all of us in
that we edit and tell our stories in a particular
way, both to ourselves and to others.
For me, the books that I’ve written are
categorized as fiction.
I certainly use some of my own experiences
in those books, but they are very much fiction,
so I think I’m doing something a little
different.
Film Courage: Right.
One of my favorite quotes is actually that,
to step out of our own story and then once
we do we see the world differently and the
people around us differently.
Did the two of you experience this in your
own lives, having watched Stephen and his
process and whether his story was totally
true or not, did you have any of your own
revelations about your lives?
Pam: Part of the appeal for me in telling
this story was the opportunity to look at
places in my own life where my narrative doesn’t
match someone else’s.
I think everybody tells the story of a break-up
differently or a relationship with a parent
and that’s fascinating.
It’s not malicious, it’s not flawed, it’s
part of who we are.
We’re narrative machines and we need to
make sense of who we are and we need to make
sense of what’s happened to us.
Film Courage: James?
James: My story about myself goes up in conflict
with sort of a public persona almost all the
time.
I am a public personality and often times
I don’t think that what is projected out
there is me.
But I’ve come to accept that as somebody
who sort of lives half of his life in public.
I know that I can’t control that version
of myself, that story that is being told by
a big collective or through a lot of different
outlets.
It certainly contrasts with who I think I
am.
But I also have kind of reconciled myself
with it, that it’s just part of my life.